ماذا ستفعل ما ستفعله لو
كان صاروخًا روسيًا
سنتحدث مع حلفائنا
معك أه مع أه مع الأمريكيين مع
الرئيس بايدن
[موسيقى]
لكني أرى الأخبار أه أن وزارتكم
أه تقول إنها كانت  صاروخ روسي ، لقد
كان صاروخًا روسيًا وزارته فقط
في وزير خارجيتنا
وقد جلس في هذا البيان
أنه صاروخ روسي بالطبع
لأنه تم إنتاجه في روسيا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[تصفيق]
صدقوني أنني أكثر حرصًا.  لا
تلوم الروسي إيمانويل ، فأنت تعلم أن هذه
حرب وأعتقد أن كلا
الجانبين سيتهمان جانبًا آخر من هذا
والجانب الآخر من هذه الحرب ، نعم
أعتقد أننا لسنا بحاجة إلى تصعيد
التصعيد بين روسيا وحلف الناتو
.  لا
أحتاجها وبالمناسبة هل تعتقد أنني
أريد العمل مع روسيا ، فلا
صدقني أنني لا أريد ذلك
، فأنا لا أريد أن أخوض حربًا مع
الروس
[موسيقى]